Lovely!
I’ve just realised that erbium is the most
crucial element for the internet
of all the elements on the periodic table,
and so I want to take you
across to materials engineering where we can
see a demonstration which
will explain to you why it’s so important,
and why without erbium many
of you couldn’t be watching this video.
Erbium is another lanthanide metal. It’s
soft, silvery, quite malleable,
very reactive towards oxygen and water and,
I suppose, for us right now
it’s quite significant, because it was originally
discovered from a mineral
which was found in this quarry. So we’re
in a quarry in Sweden near
Stockholm, called Ytterby Mine and some black
minerals that were found
in this quarry actually were the birthplace
for four new chemical
elements and erbium was one of them.
Erbium is a photographic filter and it is
actually a nuclear poison. What
that means is that it will kill dead any nuclear
fission process so it’s
obviously got some applications there. It’s
an interesting element when
you make compounds of it and dissolve it in
solution it often goes pink.
Now this is some erbium trichloride. You’ll
notice it’s very slightly pink. I
think this is one of the ones that, because
of its pink colourations, get’s
used in jewellery and things like sunglasses
and things like that, if
memory serves.
More recently erbium is used as an amplifier
of light as it’s transmitted
down optical fibres.
So, the reason we are here, and why I’m
all dressed up, these are the
fibres that transmit the signals for the internet.
Now the reason they use
fibres is because copper cables which you
would normally use for
electrical signals cannot carry nearly as
much information, as many
YouTube viewings at once, as one of these
fibres. And the fibre is very
strong, neither Brady nor I have managed to
break it, and the problem
is that even with this fibre, with the light
beam going down it, eventually
the light gets weaker and weaker and you lose
the signal. So every
50km, every 30 miles or so, down the fibre
when it’s under the sea you
have to amplify the signal to get it back
up again so that our YouTube
video can reach the other side of the Atlantic
or to India or wherever.
And so the way you’ve got to do it you’ve
got to somehow amplify the
light, make it more intense, and you can do
this with erbium because if
you put erbium into the glass then if you
shine a light onto the erbium
atoms they get excited and then as the light
comes in from the signal it
interacts with the erbium atom and the erbium
atom loses its energy and
gives out more light. So essentially the light
comes in and comes out
twice as intense. It then keeps going another
30 miles and you repeat it.
Here we’ve got the infrared laser, I used
to work with lasers, but I’ve
rather given up now. So it’s quite nostalgic.
Is it switched on? And if you
put this in the laser beam you can see there’s
a special screen here,
which will actually take an infrared laser
beam which you can’t see and
make it into visible light so you can see
it. We’ve got infrared light going
into a piece of glass with erbium in it. Now,
what is happening here is the
physics here is slightly different from what
happens in the amplifier, but
is really quite fun because the light beam
that you can’t see is suddenly
being changed into visible light, to green
light, which you can.
Yes it’s very important, I had heard about
it in lectures but when we
videoed our first video about erbium I had
completely forgotten about
this, although without it nobody would have
seen any of our videos.
Welders, people that join pieces of metal
together using either large
electric fields or extreme temperatures have
special masks to protect
their eyes from the very bright light which
is given out in the welding
process. Welding goggles typically can include
erbium salts because they
are intense and they absorb a massive amount
of the light so the eyes of
the welder are not damaged at all.
So, under the sea you have these fibres with
copper wires going next to
it carrying the currents for the diodes that
excite the amplifiers all the
way along and, apparently, the current going
down these wires is quite
attractive to sharks and so in shallow water
sharks come along and see
the cable and it seems attractive and they
start chewing it and, although
Brady and I can’t break the fibres, a shark
in full spate can easily cut
through it and so there have been quite alot
of problems with the optic
fibres in shallow water being chewed to bits
by sharks.